we used to say that the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth was six to nine months it would
appear that that timeline is
accelerating
I have here in my hand an article from
The New York Times published on October
3rd
headline how a tiny elections company
became a conspiracy theory Target this
is by Stuart a Thompson
this is these are the first sentences of
the article at an invitation only
conference in August at a secret
location southeast of Phoenix a group of
election deniers unspooled a new
conspiracy theory about the 2020
presidential outcome using threadbare
evidence or none at all the group
suggested that a small American election
software company knech had secret ties
to the Chinese Communist party and had
given the Chinese government backdoor
access to personal data about 2 million
poll workers in the United States
according to online accounts from
several people at the conference
goes on and on about the conspiracy
theory okay that's October 3rd New York
Times Stuart Thompson
October 4th
October 3rd
October 4th October 4th also by Stuart
Thompson
election software executive arrested on
suspicion of theft
this is the first the first sentences
I'm not even picking
the top executive of an elections
technology company that has been the
focus of attention among election
deniers was arrested by Los Angeles
County officials in connection with an
investigation into the possible theft of
personal information about poll workers
the county said on Tuesday and what
happened where'd they find the data Mr
gascon's office said its investigators
had found the data stored in China
ah
is is the same paper it's the same story
it's the same paper
it's the same writer
it's 24 hours apart
forget the same week or this it's
October 3rd October 4th
And yet when you look at the October 4th
article
not a hint of an apology
no oops
no official correction
just move along yeah Move Along yeah
yeah the thing we said that didn't
happen yet okay it happened yeah Move
Along Move Along nothing to see here no
no we have nothing to apologize for on
to the next dishonest attack it's a
reminder especially as we head into the
midterms that when Democrats start
harping on some conspiracy theory when
Democrats really spend a lot of time and
energy attacking some so-called
conspiracy theory you can be almost
certain that the conspiracy theory is
correct I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the drummer's
workshop at Norm's music he had it
yesterday too this guy is good this
guy's good he says on the next
Scooby-Doo episode Velma goes to Russia
to try to save Brittany
greinero
that's true of course because what the
left has to do because the left can't
create anything of its own and its
narratives are Preposterous and its
agenda is deeply unpopular what they
have to do is go into beloved
institutions and beloved characters and
beloved stories and then just rip their
guts out cut slice them open rip out
their guts then climb inside them like
Invasion of the Body Snatchers
and use those beloved characters and
institutions to to Parrot their own
unpopular and incoherent narratives
that's what they have to do that's
that's the only way it's going to work
so that's true of course we're going to
see that we're gonna we're gonna see
that next week
Mickey Mouse talking about the
importance of transiting the kids
actually they already did that one they
actually they already wow
truth is Stranger Than parody the news
is Stranger Than satire these days I
suppose you know with all of this
craziness and especially with these
attacks for for holding perfectly
ordinary abuse Common Sense views you
really are going to want to protect your
data that's why you've got to check out
expressvpn head on over to
expressvpn.com Knowles how much time do
you spend on your phone every day what
do you do on your phone every day
I don't I would say what do you spend 23
and a half hours on your phone you're
doing you're sending messages texting
calling looking up stuff online shopping
well here's what's pretty scary your
phone carrier is collecting data on
everything you're doing Verizon has even
admitted to it they say it's so that
they can better understand your
interests really all they want to do is
sell your activity to advertisers stuff
like the sites you visited what you've
been up to online that's why I use
expressvpn you should use it to
expressvpn is an app that prevents your
phone carrier from being able to see all
the sites you visit and sell it off to
third parties all it takes is one tap of
a button and all of your network data
get encrypted and rerouted through
expressvpns secure servers for ultimate
privacy one subscription can be used on
up to five devices at the same time when
your phone carrier tracks you that is a
gross invasion of your privacy you can
either keep letting them cash in on you
or visit expressvpn.com Knowles to get
the same VPN that I use and Trust take
back your online privacy today you use
my link to get three extra months for
free
expresvpn.com Knowles expressvpn.com
Knowles
a lot of conspiracy theories going
around
and a lot of them are being proven
correct
here's a conspiracy theory do you
remember there's this conspiracy theory
right wing extreme dangerous theory that
schools are trying to trans your kids
and initially the lib said this is not
true the schools are not transiting the
kids this is not being taught in school
and it's good that it is
huh yeah it's not the schools are not t
first of all they're saying they're not
teaching transgenderism and LGBT
ideology that it was pretty clear very
quickly you just look at the curricula
you look at the libraries yes they are
teaching that okay well it's good that
we're teaching that
next but they're certainly not
trying to actively
inculcate these these beliefs in your
child to cultivate and groom really
these sexual orientations and behaviors
in your child or there's that's
definitely not happening until
until we have a top national school
psychologist
who is now part of a group
offering to resettle kids
with queer parents
not their parent they're going to take
the kids away from the kids parents and
resettle them with homosexuals and other
members of the queer Community this is
the chairman chair lady I guess of the
National Association of school
psychologists lgbtq committee admitting
that she wants to put parents in their
place
to re-home that she says gay youth
the group's resources for outed students
section advises quote students who are
facing familial rejection or who need to
leave their home for another reason just
let's put a pause there what do you mean
need to leave their home for another
reason
so familial rejection is saying the kid
was thrown out of the house where the
kid's going to go okay that's one issue
it's a complicated issue that's one
issue but what about students who need
to leave their home for another reason
specifically for sexual reasons
um what is
those people are quote encouraged to
reach out to Amy she her immediately
they and I think it's confusing they do
this now because they use a plural
pronoun to refer to individuals but they
I think that means she works with safe
space Nova they are an adult
I mean I'm just going to translate this
into English she works with safe space
Nova she is an adult and can provide you
with much more information she's also
confidential
saying that PLP The Pride Liberation
project
that we're talking about here could
re-home students
who don't like their parents as well as
pay them money and have an adult pick
them up
to take them to their new lives groups
said it could provide false
documentation to hide children's
whereabouts while they participate in
the gay activities and hide them from
their parents quote in the event of you
needing to leave your home we can
provide you with emergency housing from
a supportive queer friendly adult we
will work with other supportive adult
organizations in the region to find you
someone who can provide you a kind in
affirming home I try not to take cheap
shots especially at the marginalized
same-sex attracted sort of people who
are sexually confused and I and I I do
that because I think it's so easy and
you know I think to to smear these
people is all being kind of pedophiles
or criminals or something is not a nice
thing to do and so I generally try to
avoid it
it's really hard to read this and not
think that these people are
sick perverted pedos it's really hard
when you've got these these people these
predators
who are working with predators in the
schools and school psychologists and
these these organizations and these
non-profits to Target these kids who are
having fights with their parents or who
maybe are just going through a rough
period with their parents as all teenage
kids do and say hey leave your home
we'll pay you to leave your home we'll
give you money we'll have that adult out
there and that creepy white van he'll
come and pick you up and they'll take
you to the nice really nice home of a
really nice queer man and he'll take
good good care of you it's really hard
to read that
in in a charitable way I think the most
charitable way you can read that is
these people are sick and obviously
perverted and probably Predators right
when you have that kind of an interest
in someone else's 12 year old
something's wrong okay when you've got
that kind of an interest in someone
else's 12 year old's sexual desires and
behavior something is wrong with you and
you need to seek help and you probably
need to be kept away from polite Society
just a conspiracy theory though right
right no no we're not we're not trying
to trans and queer your kids and that's
why we're sending that creepy creepy old
40 year old Billy over there in the
white van good old Billy from where he's
the one wearing the leather vest yeah
he's going to just come pick up your 12
year old and take him away from you and
hide him and give him money
and talk about sexuality with him right
yeah it's a total conspiracy theory
though right you want to talk about
another conspiracy theory you remember
again on the transgender topic we were
told no no there no hospitals or
transiting the kids this is completely
ridiculous no one is the transgender
surgery is for adults people over 18.
okay maybe some 17 year olds okay maybe
some 16 year olds okay maybe some 13
year olds okay actually and you've got
it in in the reporting from people like
Libs of tick tock and the handful of
other actual journalists out there oh
yeah actually these kinds of procedures
and chemicals and cross-ex hormones
puberty blockers these are being given
to kids who are much much younger well
there's some good news on that front the
Governor of Oklahoma
Governor Kevin Stitt signed a bill
that prohibits gender transition
services for children at the at an
Oklahoma Pediatric Hospital okay so
that's good and it's because the
hospital is reliant on state funds so he
can say okay we're not going to pass on
certain funds that we are in possession
of that might come from the federal
government too but he wants to go
further because it doesn't actually
Outlaw this it hopefully will stop it
and put a lot of pressure on it but he
says I'm calling for the legislature to
ban all irreversible gender transition
surgeries and hormone therapies on
minors
when they convene next session in
February 2023. now there's a little bit
of wiggle room here irreversible I
wouldn't because the the libs are going
to dispute that it's irreversible even
though it usually is but he's obviously
moving in the right direction this is
good you just got to watch the language
he says we cannot turn a blind eye to
what's happening all across our nation
and as Governor I will not allow
life-altering transition surgeries on
minor children in the state of Oklahoma
great stuff I strongly applaud you
Governor Kevin Stitt hey other
Republican Governors where are you where
are the rest of you I know that some
Republican Governors are making
movements on this front right now let's
do it let's get it done I don't even
want to wait until the next legislative
session let's get it done right now
because the longer this goes with those
Republican Governors not doing this the
more I'm starting to think they're
squishes the more I'm starting to think
they're fine with transiting the kids we
know some of them are ASA Hutchinson
he's a fake Republican governor in
Arkansas he's fine with transiting the
kids okay don't be like ASA Hutchins be
like be like Governor Stitt do not be
like Governor Hutchinson okay we're
gonna have to do this stuff ourselves
folks we're going to have to make our
voices heard and make sure that our
Representatives do what is right here
when you want to fix your car yourself
you got to check out rockauto.com right
now go to rockauto.com and write nulls
in there how did you hear about his box
did you know that chain stores have
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and do-it-yourselfers
rockauto.com's prices are the same for
everybody and they are reliably low I
love that these guys don't get gimmicky
and on Tuesday save 20 and on this day
no it's just always the lowest prices
possible
they are always giving you a fair rate
whether you're a pro whether you're a
do-it-yourselfer whether it's for your
classic or your daily driver you can get
everything that you need with just a few
easy clicks delivered straight to your
door the rockauto.com catalog is super
easy to navigate so easy even I can do
it you can quickly see all the parts
available for your car or truck head on
over there right now why wouldn't you go
to rockauto.com check out all those
parts available for your automobile
rockauto.com and then be sure to write
nulls candlew Less in there how did you
hear about this box so they know that we
sent you
all these crazy conspiracy theories that
just all turned out to be true yes they
are indoctrinating kids into the weird
LGBT stuff yes they are encouraging kids
to engage in this kind of behavior and
and indulge these sexual identities yes
they are overtly transiting the kids
this is all happening and one of my
colleagues has made a Jihad out of this
issue and that would be my colleague
Matt Walsh who has an excellent movie on
the subject what is a woman he's putting
a ton of pressure media pressure on
politicians here in the state of
Tennessee and around the country
to change these laws I think he's been
very very effective at that he's doing a
really good job so what happens what
happens when you pose a threat to the
establishment
here's the hit piece here we go baby
this is good from our uh our good
friends over at Media Matters our
publicists we've got Matt Walsh's sordid
history as a radio host exposed
as the co-host of the matte and crank
program Matt Walsh defended political
violence and teen pregnancy he's shocked
an intern with a stun gun so just on
that that last one right there that's
funny that's good I think actually I
think that builds character when you can
I know it's not permitted in every
jurisdiction now but I think the interns
would get a lot better work done if you
get every once in a while just kind of
Zap them you know but okay again I no
context here right he performed racist
impressions of black men well everything
that conservatives do is racist
according to these people so okay did
that and he said that we we probably
lost our Republic after reconstruction
okay
so I went through I'm not going to go
through this this article is so long and
it would be kind of weird for me to read
our publicists work on the air right my
job here is to just be on the air and
then our publicists at Media Matters can
put it all out there but but I went
through it I went through I said okay
what's the best they got what's the best
they got on this guy uh dig it up let me
see baby this is the one that's just
launching his kind of stopped trancing
the kids tour right now so this is the
day that's obviously timed to be a
political attack what do they got and
I'm looking through it all
it's it's just stuff that he
St other than you know stupid jokes like
you shock the intern or something it's
just generally just stuff that he still
talks about
Matt Walsh
says there's a great replacement theory
he talked about that on Backstage like a
week ago
Matt Walsh
believes that we shouldn't trans the
kids uh yeah that's true so it's
basically the big the big headline here
is Matt Walsh continues to believe the
things that he says he believes
that's and that's the best they got
so that's pretty amazing if this you got
a whole research team Media Matters
funded you know with a lot of money this
is the best they could do I don't know
I don't know I think I could probably
dig up better stuff on Walsh that's
pretty pretty weak stuff but what's it
really about it's not about Matt Walsh
it's not about this local radio show
that he was on 10 years ago it's not
about it's not even about the poor
intern who apparently was shocked on
camera or something by the way I I was
almost electrocuted three days ago
when I had the labor simulator on my abs
for 20 minutes no one no I don't hear
any any Lamentations for me where's my
pity piece and Media Matters no only for
the interns do they get that but
regardless it's not about math it's not
about any of that stuff this is about
shutting down the hospitals
all the all this info's been out there
forever we've all had our shows for
years this is because right now
Matt is trying to shut down these
pediatric gender clinics and because he
at the moment is one of the big faces of
it they're just going to go after him
because they really don't want to shut
down the hospitals and they don't want
to shut down the and when I say
hospitals I mean quack Shaman Witch
Doctor mutilation pervert boot camps
where they take confused kids and then
chop off their body parts and pump them
full of the wrong hormones and things
like that so obviously these things
should be shut down why are the lips
pushing for it there's the I've said it
on the show for days now
well I've said it for longer but I've
been focusing on it for the past few
days there's an ideological component
the libs really do want to upend the
world the libs actually hate reality as
it is that the libs hate norms and
traditions and standards in the moral
order
so they want to invert all of that it's
uh it's that line that Democrats quote
all the time going back to JFK that is
actually a quote from George Bernard
Shaw's play cycle back to Methuselah
which is actually a quote from the
serpent in the Garden of Eden tempting
Eve and the line is this some people see
things that are and say why I dream
things that never were and say why not
and that's that's the distinction right
there right conservatives are looking at
the way things are and they're saying
why why do things work this way what is
it what is human nature really like what
is the world what what are we here for
what is the purpose of all these things
right and the libs look at the world and
they say I hate this I want to I want to
remake all of this I want to be as Gods
as you know ye shall be as Gods is the
line from the serpent in the Garden of
Eden tempting even it's a line that
Whitaker Chambers after he had left
communism famously said that's that's
the beginning of Communism that's the
beginning of this kind of radical
leftism so that's that's really what
it's all about and that's the
ideological side then there's the
financial side which is these these
gender hospitals these these quack
procedures generate a ton of money and
and so it's not just the red medical
kind of communist leftist out element
there's a cold Hard Cash capitalist
element here too which is that big
corporations are going to make a lot
more money if they if they convince
people to take these quote the words of
Public Health administrators Big Money
Maker surgeries and procedures that then
get them on a subscription plan of
hormones and and fix me up procedures
for the rest of their lives and so if
you can start someone on that at 20 that
makes some amount of money for big
Pharma what about if you can get them on
at 16 what about at 12 what about at
eight that's more and more money for for
a very expensive procedures for a much
longer time
so yeah they're going to go after him
because it's what they believe in their
own kind of perverted views of the world
but it's also because there's big money
on the line as well speaking of dredging
up the past there's a story that broke a
couple days ago about Georgia Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker also
you know sports legend just absolute you
know
OG kind of very very popular guy in the
culture now he's running for Senate as a
republican so here here are the attacks
on Herschel Walker
his son came out and tweeted out how
angry he is at Herschel and he doesn't
like Herschel and he doesn't think
Herschel should have run for Senate and
herschel's a bad father and he walked
out on them and he slept with all these
women and he was his big domineering
scary guy and okay so that's
that's from the Sun and then the second
attack which I think is is a bigger deal
is there's an allegation published in
The Daily Beast which is a left-wing rag
that says that Herschel Walker paid for
an abortion in 2009 and they claim to
have receipts and they claim to have a
check and they claim to have you know a
get well soon card from Herschel Walker
to this alleged baby mama
but Herschel Walker is very pro-life so
there he is he's a hypocrite and he
killed a baby that's what they're saying
uh is it true or not
the closer to election day that these
kinds of stories and attacks come out
the less credibility I think they have
this is what is called an October
surprise you wait on some really damning
information until October in the hopes
of killing the candidate and also
because if the news comes out in October
especially with early voting then
there's no time to fact check it so they
make these allegations what do they say
Trump colluded with the Russians he's a
Russian stooge he he urinated on a
prostitute in Moscow with the most
ridiculous sort of things and then yeah
it comes out a couple of years later
that that was all completely bogus but
it doesn't matter because the election
takes place a month or two later so I am
skeptical of of all this stuff
that Herschel was this you know knuckle
dragging absolute Terror of a father who
put his whole family's life at risk and
you know I that
I'm skept maybe I just don't know I know
that we've seen in in other cases
herschel's son seems to have a good
relationship with his father and seems
to be supportive so again and I think
it's really really hideous of the libs
and the Democrats to exploit the man's
son this way to turn the son against the
father absolutely hideous it would be
hard for me to forgive that but then
what about the abortion I don't know
again I don't believe it because it's
coming out so late
and I saw other reports that Herschel
Walker had had children out of wedlock
and so I again I don't know I don't pay
attention to this tabloid stuff but it
would be strange if you have kids out of
wedlock already why why you would then
say no we can't have any kids out of
wedlock I'm going to pay for an abortion
or something that to me is a little
incoherent but again
putting all of that aside
let's say it were true let's say on the
very slight chance it were true
obviously that's a terrible sin
obviously the guy should should go
confess his sins
I hope he's repented I hope that he's
sincerely pro-life
but when it comes down to how I would
vote if I were a citizen of Georgia
voting on Election Day and I were
pro-life
that's no that's no question that's a
no-brainer
Herschel Walker was running on a
pro-life platform
Rafael Warnock is a radically
pro-abortion politician
no matter what egregious sort of
personal sin is in Herschel Walker's
past even if it did include an abortion
which again I'm saying I don't Herschel
Walker denies it and I see no reason to
trust The Daily Beast over Herschel
Walker but even if it were true that's
not that's not a hard decision for me
okay in the one case we get a guy who
maybe he's a hypocrite or maybe he's not
a hypocrite maybe he actually just like
all of us has standards and doesn't live
up to them all the time
and he is he is pro-life and will vote
pro-life and supports life causes as a
public figure or I got this crazy
radical socialist pro-abortion guy who
wants to kill all the babies that's not
hard for me that's not a difficult so I
don't know that this attack
totally lands
and I don't I don't see how it moves the
needle people might be disappointed or
they were they if they even believe it
at all they might just dismiss it
Herschel says that his fundraisers went
through the roof after this attack came
out because they see it as being
dishonest and unfair either way I don't
see how this really moves the needle for
Warnock in Georgia
speaking of the past
this is the saddest story there have
been a lot of sad stories recently this
is one of the saddest stories I've seen
recently
comes from McDonald's I actually this
was really weird timing because the
story just broke today but last night
was it last night I think it was
or two nights ago I was I was getting
back from a speech it was two nights ago
I'm getting back from a speech
and I I arrived late I hadn't had dinner
and I say okay I'm getting a little Mac
attack right now I want to get a little
Double Quarter Pounder with cheese
before I get home it's late Elise has
already had her dinner plus I can sneak
a little fast food you know and at least
it's not looking okay great so I pull up
and I see this weird thing on the menu
at McDonald's it says it's a
I forget what they called it was some
weird co-branding thing and it looked it
looked like a Happy Meal but it was
clearly for adults and it's a limited
edition but it was that little box you
know you used to get for the Happy Meals
I said ah whatever ordered my quarter
pounder with cheese went home had a nice
night
find out today McDonald's is launching
happy meals for adults
they say quote we're taking one of the
most nostalgic McDonald's experiences
and literally repackaging it in a way
literally people use that word literally
way too much repackaging it in a new way
that's hyper relevant for our adult fans
McDonald's USA Chief marketing and
customer experience officer Tariq Hassan
said in a press release everyone
remembers their first Happy Meal as a
kid and they can't sit still feeling as
you dug in to see what was inside that
little red box could turn a regular
Tuesday into the best day ever and now
we're reimagining that experience in a
whole new way this time for adults so
what does it come with it's in a box
similar kind of box and you open it up
instead of the tiny little cheeseburger
it's a Big Mac because you're supposed
to be an adult now and instead of the
tiny little drink it's a big size drink
instead of the tiny little fries it's
bigger fries
and there's a toy
there it comes with a toy
because you're an adult but you're in a
stat you're going to go back and relive
that exp this is so sad man my
generation is so freaking sad it's the
Millennials are just it's just pathetic
because this generation just won't grow
up
yeah I like nostalgic things yeah when I
think of the 90s that well that was fun
90s fashion and boy it was nice being a
kid in some ways although don't forget
nostalgia's history after a few drinks
okay wasn't really the way you remember
it but okay
why do I need to pretend to be a kid
again
why are why do Millennials just why
won't Millennials grow
up grow up get married have kids get a
normal job
grow up man oh my gosh well come on
Michael don't be such a downer you know
it's fun to relive your childhood you
know the crazy part I agree with that
it is fun to relive your childhood do
you know how you relive your childhood
in a normal way you have kids and then
do things with them it's so it saddens
me so much
when I see my fellow Millennials going
to Disney World
alone
not with kids not even forget let's say
they can't have their own kids not even
with their nieces or nephews or no not
nothing they go alone and they go on the
rides themselves they're in their 30s
and then they go
what do they do they go and get the
Happy Meal and they they try to collect
all the little toys so they can put the
toys next to their other toy collection
in their overgrown child dystopia guys
grow up man growing up is good
I know we all have this Nostalgia for
our past let me tell you something
barring you know certain years people
have bad things happen traumas and
things but if you just I'm saying year
over year I think my life has gotten
better every single year of my life I
love it I look forward to the future I
do not fear getting old I love it I look
I want to see my kids grow up I wanna I
wanna continue to do work that I find
important and that I want to build a
life with my family I don't want to
return to the freaking playpen and play
with little Grimace toys and and suck on
my Happy Meal
slurp up a little you know Coca-Cola and
eat a cheeseburger okay it's you can do
it with your kids it's this it reminds
me of that song by Kenny Loggins you
know do you know the song poop back to
Pooh Corner so help me if you can I've
gotta get back it's this whole thing
about he wrote it when he was graduating
high school how he was lost in the woods
and he's got to get back to Pooh Corner
and what happened to Winnie the Pooh and
all of his friends I can't find them
anymore and he's coming to terms with
leaving childhood and graduating high
school and moving on and becoming an
adult
he says I just want to get back to Pooh
Corner but I can't because that's over
now I'm going a little further today
than I thought I could and all right I'm
out of here right but then he revisits
the song he writes after he had a kid he
he writes another stanza and he says you
know
I have made it back to Pooh Corner
because I'm looking at my son right now
playing with my old little toys
but we can't we don't do that as
Millennials it's just it's this
generation of completely stunted growth
and it's really sad and I I don't know
why was it a failure of our parents sure
blame your parents is it a failure of
the economy okay blame the economy is it
a failure of this everybody else's fault
other than Iran okay fine blame whoever
you want I'm just telling you guys oh
I'm preaching to the choir with you but
I'm telling the people who are getting
the adult happy meal
growing up is good it's good I know it's
scary and I know you don't don't gosh if
I get married then I won't be able to
sleep with everyone else you're right oh
gosh if I have kids I'll I'll have to be
accountable and responsible yes you will
oh that's scary yeah it's scary it's
worth it growing up is worth it when I
was a child I ate Happy Meals when I
became an adult I put away childish
things and I bought happy meals for my
little kid okay
and for me I buy Double Quarter Pounders
with cheese
speaking of childish behavior
Howard Stern
our you know shock jock Howard Stern
has has just made headlines for leaving
his house for the first time in two
years
first time in two years do you know why
covid
covid
this is real
I didn't believe this at first he Howard
Stern has not had not left his house for
two years
he's always been a germaphobe
and
he is just deathly neurotically afraid
of getting coveted and so finally some
of his
his celebrity friends coaxed him out
he talked about this on on his show he
said
I really had an exhausting weekend
emotionally physically for the first
time in two years I ventured out of the
house it was too much for me it was too
much
I haven't been out in two years
he said Jimmy Kimmel had been urging him
to come out he said Kimmel came over to
visit him and Stern has been demanding
that whoever visits him take covid tests
before they come into the house and the
wife Howard Stern's wife wanted to leave
but Howard said no no
he said I said to my wife before this
dinner I don't want to go I'm in a panic
I don't want to get covered
he said effort I know I'm being a wuss I
know I'm cleaning up the language a
little but for me covet is still going
on and I haven't left my house I can't
figure out how to integrate myself I've
been locked up so long and I haven't
gotten coveted I'm afraid I'll be the
one a-hole who gets coveted and I'll die
even though people don't seem to be
dying that much anymore he's still so
afraid I know I know people like this
I have friends and relatives who who
still
really don't eat inside restaurants
they'll try to eat outside even if it's
blistering hot even if it's freezing
cold they just don't they're just too
they're so neurotically afraid of covid
and it's the same thing it's the same
impulse
Howard Stern is is experiencing that the
Millennials who want to buy the adult
Happy Meal are experiencing
it's just
that the refusal to accept
life as it is that you're born
and you live
and you die
and time moves on and we live in time
and space and you don't get to freeze
Time Forever
and circumstances change
people get sick and time moves on and
you've got to make good use of your time
think about Howard Stern oh my gosh he's
lost two years of his life
two years let's say Howard Stern lives
to 90 years old
he'll he'll really have lived for 88
years right he want those two years he's
been hunkered down like a complete
maniac
and I think about this with the
overgrown children Millennials who still
want to you know who are still shocked
when they if they pay their own cell
phone plan which is uh infrequent
because a lot of them are on their
family cell phone plans but if they pay
their own bills every now and again
they'll say I'm adulting I'm adulting as
though they deserve a cookie for for
doing things that that 30 year olds are
expected to do
no and you just think about okay they
live to be 90 years old but emotionally
they're still 16. that's sad they've
missed a lot of their life
yeah they've missed the hard parts and
the suffering and the prospect of
sickness and the the risk of death even
they've missed those things because
they've been so coddled and they've been
so so uh cautious and they've been so
afraid to actually live but they miss
life too that's what they've also missed
that's not good we need to we need to
return to some semblance of normal
okay we need to we need to recognize
sickness happens suffering happens it's
okay responsibilities happen you're not
going to get to sleep as much when you
get married and have kids you're not you
have to work a little harder you're
gonna have to make a little bit more
money okay that's fine you're going to
die someday that's true that's the way
it is just don't why would you live in
constant fear of that if you live this
is a trick of the devil but if the if
you live constantly harping on the past
whether out of anxiety or out of
nostalgia
and or if you live on the future and
trying to protect that future so you
never get sick and you never die or
anything you completely miss the present
which is the only place where you can
actually live you only live in the
present
so either way you spend all your life in
the thinking about the past daydreaming
or daydreaming about the future you're
not living in the present
grow up not you you know what you're
doing but these crazy people out there
they got to grow up
one part of growing up is you start
shaving this Monday we will be
celebrating one of my absolute favorite
holidays at one of the left's least
favorite holidays Columbus Day and while
many woke companies will ignore or
attempt to Rebrand this holiday
Jeremy's razors will honor it with an
historic sale
from now through October 12th you can
purchase a Founders series shave kit for
40 off plus free shipping that's a one
percent discount for each of the 40
Christopher Columbus statues that have
been removed or destroyed in this
country by illiterate buffoons
it's time to stand up and celebrate
history in defiance of those who wish to
cancel it stop giving your money to woke
razor companies that hate you give it to
Jeremy instead navigate your way
to jeremy'sraisers.com enjoy a sale for
the ages
speaking of returning to normal I
mentioned yesterday that Elon Musk is
looks like he's going to actually be
buying Twitter
what that means is
the the only thing that might forget
about we can voice our views we
conservatives finally have a shot forget
about our follower counts forget
it means that Trump can return
Elon Musk has already said he said I
think Banning Trump was a mistake
because it alienated a large part of the
country and did not ultimately result in
Donald Trump not having a voice he said
the decision was morally bad so it's not
just that it was tactically sort of bad
he said it's morally bad
and he says that he would reverse the
permanent ban
now this is complicated because Trump
has said that even if the ban is lifted
he won't go back to Twitter
he'll remain on his own platform which
is truth social and presumably when he
signed on to truth social it included
some Provisions in the contract that say
he can't go back to Twitter or something
right because that would that would
really gut truth social and Trump
doesn't want to do that
so what's he going to do he's in a
really tough position right now
this is one of the toughest political
positions Trump is in the the only one
that's tougher is the covid vaccines
because Donald Trump did allow fauci to
have more of a platform Trump did not
reopen the country after Easter as he
had sort of dangled out there that he
could which I think would have been
amazing uh he did
get us the vaccines which he has gotten
a lot of credit for but the vaccines
have a lot of problems and then there
were vaccine mandates not because of
Trump trump didn't want to mandate them
but then the mandates came in later and
so Trump is in this tough position where
a lot of his base myself included hates
the lockdowns and doesn't like the
vaccines and
he was one of the Defenders of the
vaccines albeit not demanding so that's
it's just that's a tricky one for him to
navigate and then this one is tricky for
him to navigate
because
if he refuses to get back on Twitter
it looks like he's just privileging his
private business interests over his
political life
Eric could look that way and he would be
limiting his reach because people just
don't use truth social the only reason
people use truth social is to see what
Trump is saying and then they share it
to other social media platforms so we I
read a bunch of Truth social posts but I
read it I just really read what Trump
writes because I'm just interested in
what he has to say so
that's what happens if he just stays on
Truth social but if he goes over to
Twitter one it guts true social right so
this company just goes away and
two
it might be seen as though he's going
back and playing by their rules he said
he wouldn't do it and then he did it
anyway now where do I come down on this
I want him to have his Twitter again he
should do it they don't want him to have
Twitter
he will have a much broader reach if
he's on Twitter I want him to go back on
Twitter I think it is likely to help him
and his prospects in 2024 which are
still very very strong he's atop the
Heap by a long shot but especially in
Florida DeSantis now has a lead over
Trump in a prospective 2024 presidential
race I think in the middle of the
country Trump is still just so much
stronger and better known than DeSantis
is DeSantis just hasn't been around that
long obviously doesn't have the name
recognition that goes along with being a
celebrity for 40 years and the president
for one term
but
still if you're a trump you got to be a
little worried about that and so
and then the most important reason I
think Trump should go back on Twitter I
would find it very entertaining I would
love that I would love it I would get to
retweet it a lot and so I strongly
encourage him to do that
speaking of people running for president
and Trump's Prospect Nikki Haley is
headed out on tour with her new book if
you want something done Leadership
Lessons from Bold women
and she's planning to campaign for a
bunch of Republican candidates ahead of
the midterm elections in November while
she's on this book tour
and
she has intimated that she's interested
in running for president she's been a
little unclear about would she run will
she not run she says she won't run if
Trump runs but then she's kind of
positioning herself to run
you know she wants to run
so what does this tell me
whatever whatever it means about Nikki
Haley's personal political career it
tells me that Trump is not quite as
secure in the nomination as
a lot of people think that he is
the reason I say that is
not because of what the politicians are
saying virtually all the politicians are
saying that they will not run if Trump
runs
and yet they're all doing the sort of
things that candidates do as they
prepare to run Pompeo seems to be
preparing a presidential campaign Mike
Penn seems to be preparing a
presidential campaign Nikki Haley seems
to be preparing a presidential campaign
Tim Scott's publisher got in a lot of
trouble because the publisher wrote on a
book flap that was leaked that he is
preparing a presidential campaign Tim
Scott also is doing the things that
people would expect a candidate to do so
that's just four people right there do I
think that those four people could beat
Trump no I'm not saying that
but politicians
politicians whose names you know
are very good at politics
they have made it to the very top of the
they're The Varsity politicians okay
they are division one politicians
and so the very fact that they are
positioning themselves in this way
tells me that they very astute political
observers at least think that there is
some serious chance that Donald Trump
either doesn't run or isn't strong
enough to just completely dominate The
Field in 2024.
more reasons for Trump if he is going to
run to really start to get a little bit
more aggressive about
2024. now who's going to run on the
other side people have been saying
there's no way that Joe Biden runs right
you Kamala Harris is practically already
running for president he's trying to not
successfully Pete Buda judge same thing
he is basically running for president
already and he and Kamal are trying to
shive one another uh speaking of sharp
objects Mrs Tomahawk Senator Elizabeth
Warren clearly wants to run for
president again and then Gavin Newsom is
running TV ads in Florida so he is
running for president and he's saying he
won't run if Biden runs but again he is
beginning a campaign
Joe Biden says he's running
there was just another story came out
from Al Sharpton
Al Sharpton very plugged in Democrat
extortion artist he's been around for
many decades Al Sharpton says that Joe
Biden told him quote I'm going to do it
again
as they posed for a shot in the
Roosevelt room he says I am going
I'm I'm doing it I'm running for
president so again maybe it's just
Bluster maybe he doesn't want to be seen
as a an empty suit
we're a lame duck
but if I'm Joe Biden I'm looking around
and I'm thinking look I hate all of
these people I hate kamalai he hates
Kamala Harris right Kamala Harris whose
presidential campaign
the best moment of it was when she
called Joe Biden a racist who supported
segregation
so Kamala hates her guts doesn't want
her to be president
Newsom I don't know what he thinks about
Newsom who to judge he beat out Buddha
judge I don't think he cares that much
about Buddha Jed Buddha judge also is
not going to be president
I don't see him running any or I don't
see him winning anytime soon
uh and then Elizabeth Warren I don't
think he cares for her very much the
party he doesn't really seem to like and
so
it's possible that Joe Biden actually
runs again which would be
freaking hilarious it would be so funny
this guy is bad now this guy has got no
record to run on now he's
humiliates himself daily
the presidential race is two years away
come on man come on Jack I mean what's
he gonna run on
things just things just keep getting
worse Marcia Blackburn had a great great
little monologue here just in in just
one minute she distilled everything
wrong with The Biden energy policy
what we know is the White House wants to
say well this is a nuanced issue there
is nothing nuanced about being
intentional in what you're doing day one
declaring an end to the Keystone
Pipeline ending offshore uh putting a
million acres in Alaska Out Of Reach no
new leases ending fracking uh drawing
down the Strategic petroleum Reserve at
a billion barrels a day with no plans I
mean a million barrels a day no plans to
refill this no plans so of course the
prices going up and the interesting
thing OPEC will vote tomorrow about
whether or not they want to limit
production and we have to bear in mind
we have no leverage with OPEC the OPEC
nations combined together are one of the
top five holders of U.S debt we have no
Leverage
I could go right back up
so succinct really really articulate
Marcia Blackburn really just Nails him
right there and these are Urgent issues
okay these are issues I think that will
matter in the midterms you know I'm as
much of a culture Warrior as they get
and I frequently point out the Democrats
transiting the kids and turning the
freaking frogs gay and I'm I'm totally
into the cultural issues
at this point in the campaign I think
the cultural issues are energizing the
right people and that's all there for
the people who are not paying a lot of
attention to politics who are sort of on
sitting on the fence or who are not
particularly partisan or ideological
these are real urgent issues we are
heading into winter gas prices are
brutally high right now energy costs
generally brutally high it's about to
get cold it's going to be a long cold
winter people are going to need to heat
their homes okay I'm thinking the kind
of voter I'm thinking about right now is
that guy the other day when uh after the
hurricane in Florida DeSantis was going
around doing his kind of reconstruction
tour and this guy
he's wearing a wife beater I think he
goes man you know I'm look I'm a
Democrat and everything but I'm voting
to Sanders that guy is good he showed up
here I like him I listen I'm voting to
Sanders and he didn't really give much
of a reason why other than yeah he's
kind of confident he shows up he cares
man these other these other guys are not
confident so I'll vote to Santas
that guy that voter is who Republicans
have to reach
and there is beyond all the ideological
issues that's why the only thing
Democrats are trying to talk about now
is abortion
but abortion doesn't really motivate all
that many people pro-life or pro-choice
it doesn't really motivate people all
that much but they're really trying to
make this this ideological battle and
the Republicans are the fascists and the
threats to democracy and and evil
terrible no good rotten conspiracy
theorists and I I think there's a really
important argument that the Republicans
have to make which is just like yeah
okay all that's BS or whatever talk
about those issues if you want
also everything that the Democrats are
touching is turning to Absolute Ash
okay everything that they're touching
before actually before we I want to get
to the member block before we get to it
though Pete Buddha judge
totally summed this up poor people to
judge obviously wants to run for
president he is the uh Transportation
secretary he goes on TV because he's
been trying to get everyone to buy
Teslas you got to buy electric cars go
buy electric vehicles that's going to
solve the you can't afford seven dollar
a gallon gasoline we'll buy a 50 000
Tesla why what's so well you guys are
such dummies just go out there and buy a
hundred thousand dollar car because
because you can't afford to put gas in
your 98 Chevy okay yeah that's a great
idea people to judge thanks he he now
after the rolling blackouts after the
threats to the the electrical Grid in
especially in the liberal states he was
asked okay really are you suggesting
electrical Vehicles that's that's really
the way we're going to go into the
future he says absolutely no time like
the present
much of the power was out across half
the State of Florida for a while much of
it is resumed sir but uh it did make
some folks think boy these electric
vehicles that are being pushed between
what happened in Florida and the grid
that was compromised to the point where
California governor Newsom wanted people
to cool it for a while on when and how
often they charge the EVs do you think
this reminds folks that we're not ready
or the EVS are not ready for prime time
well actually I think this is a great
example of one of the many benefits of
those tools you know it's just at the
Detroit Auto Show a couple weeks ago one
of the things that was very impressive
about some of the vehicles that we saw
uh including the uh for example the the
pickup trucks that are on the market
entering onto the market right now is
that their power can actually flow both
ways so in an extreme event from a
neighborhood resiliency perspective they
can actually work basically like a
generator except that you don't have to
have a diesel ready for them what
they're doing is they're using the
battery capacity to uh to power a home
and and in that sense could be very
useful in a scenario like this you got
to give Pete bootage Edge Credit for
cleverness he's got that just sort of
Harvard McKinsey smarmy little answer
for everything that's not totally
convincing but it's at least articulate
enough actually no it's really great as
the power grids are failing in the blue
States it's actually really great to
have an electric car because you can't
charge it but the car can can charge
your toaster or whatever your cell phone
so it works in Reverse yeah it can work
in reverse the problem is the car's dead
yeah the problem is during the last
power grid failures in California
people couldn't power their car so they
didn't have any power in the electric
car the car was out of power that's why
they had to plug in
dirty filthy fossil fuel generators into
the car to charge the car yeah it's
great if the car were charged then you
could use it to charge your other things
in a blackout it's like saying if I had
some ham I could have ham and eggs if I
had some eggs yeah it's a lot of ifs
buddy if ifs and buts were candy and
nuts we'd all have a Merry Christmas
okay the rest of the show is continuing
now you do not want to miss it we've got
fake headlines
we've got the real headlines from the
week there's one fake headline in there
the producers have sent these to me you
have to guess and then I have to guess
which the fake headline is I've been on
a roll so far we will see how it is
going over at the member block see you
there
[Music]
[Music]